watch this oh there's mason
mason
look at how little he is the kardashian
kids are watching their past come to
life
for the first time i'm courtney i'm the
oldest
and the most on keeping up with the
kardashians
kim kardashian kourtney kardashian and
scott disick
team up to share special moments of
their kids captured on the show
over the past 11 years initially
scott explained there's a family rule
that the kids don't watch the show
but tonight they're making an exception
there's so many amazing things that you
guys have experienced
while we have filmed so we broke it down
into small clips involving just you kids
so you could see kim and kanye's kids
north and saint west and scott and
courtney's kids
mason rayne and penelope disick all had
front row seats to the screening
check out the kids watching this
memorable scene when court gave birth to
mason
watch this oh there's mason
mason
look at how little he is i love it
turns out penelope yeah she's not a fan
of this kind of thing
why are you crying why are you
i'm not crying yeah you are panel
no my eyes are watering because it's so
disgusting you just gotta roll with it
during the episode kim explains why
she's resisted
showing her kids their long-running
reality show
recently my kids have asked to watch the
show but
i'm really hesitant i think just because
i'm going to have to
me personally when scott asks kim if
north has seen the show
she reveals the seven-year-old has only
seen some clips on social media
she sees like it's a popular tick tock
where like they
they do the crying scene from the poor
abora
yeah are pretty much all my crying
scenes so she sees that stuff and she'll
come in and go mom i lost my hearing son
[Music]
kim also explains she's dreading this
conversation
i don't really want to explain like who
chris humphries is that thought that is
your life that is your past
after a whirlwind romance kim and chris
got married in august 2011
in front of cameras for a two-part tv
special
in accord with the laws of the state of
california i pronounce
you husband and wife chris you may kiss
your bride
but just 72 days later the reality star
filed for divorce
at some point they're going to be
interested in seeing everything
they're either gonna do it without us or
with us i get that
and i'd rather do it with i'd rather be
that parent
but i'm just not ready for the kids to
see it yet
meanwhile more challenges for the famous
family in a preview for next week's
episode
just tested positive for kobe trying to
not freak anyone out but i'm just really
worried north is saying she's feeling
sick
never a dull moment in the world of the
kardashians
this season marks their 20th and final
season of keeping up
in talking to the family this was a very
very hard decision for them to make
in september the show's executive
producer ryan seacrest
opened up about the famous family's
decision to walk away
you look back at 14 years and 20 seasons
of a camera in your life
and think about that at some point
you're gonna say
you know we did it we had a great run
we're going to live with a little more
privacy in our lives and i think they
just felt like
now is the time to do it but they'll be
back on tv
soon the family has inked a major new
deal with hulu
you